der papst rockt mit dem musikalbum
erwartet schlägt papst franziskus neue
töne im vatikan an der himmlische sound
von e-gitarren und seine göttliche
stimme
so soll seine botschaft jeden erreichen
der part der stellvertreter christi so
pontifex maximus heißt der große
brückenbauer
der mann muss inszenieren er soll zu den
völkern der welt sprechen nicht so zu
allen gläubigen sondern auch zu den
ungläubigen der papst er erzählt das
cover des rolling stone magazin er
twittert da ist es nur konsequent dass
auch sein album modern klingen soll
11 auszüge aus seinen gebeten und
predigten wurden dafür mit pop sound
unterlegt
sind diese klänge treffen auf
gregorianische choräle
und es wird auch mal rockig dieser papst
stellt sich weniger um konventionen sein
erster öffentlicher auftritt im
schmucklosen talar und mit schlichter
botschaft wie kann die idee für dieses
musikalbum in dem moment als papst
franziskus nach seiner wahl auf den
balkon trat und sagte brüder und
schwestern
guten abend mit diesem guten abend wurde
mir bewusst dass dieser papst ganz
anders als all seine vorgänger sein
würde
musik alben von katholischen
kirchenoberhaupt an haben mittlerweile
tradition
papst johannes paul der zweite schafft
es 1999 mit aber pater weltweit in die
charts
auch sein nachfolger benedikt der
sechzehnte lässt seine worte musikalisch
untermalen ebenfalls mit klassischer
musik in den vergangenen jahren hat die
kirche immer wieder die charts erobert
etwa mit dem chor der zisterzienser
mönche aus österreich oder den drei
irischen geistlichen getrickst
besonderes aufsehen erregt ist der
christina
die italienischen nonne christinas
kucera gewinnt eine castingshow und
begeistert mit ihrem madonna cover like
a virgin millionen
wimmer
wir haben weltweit ein phänomen der
steigenden sinnsuche kirchen religionen
sind sind angebot wenn ich das moderne
machen wenn ich das zeitgemäße machen
wir nicht das locker mache ich das
sympathisch mache erreiche ich mehr
leute ich erreiche jüngere leute diesen
zweck verfolgt auch das pop album von
papst franziskus und es ist ausdruck
seiner art der amtsführung er verzichtet
auf privilegien er vermeidet punkt und
gibt sich volksnah
typisch für ihn symbolische gesten wie
hier die fußwaschung von strafgefangenen
es ist für die katholische kirche ein
modernisierungsschub
weil alles das was von vielen menschen
als abgehoben gestelzt ritualisiert
fremd auch noch heute lateinisch
erscheint weg ist weil volksnähe da ist
popularität da ist weil einfachheit
bescheidenheit da ist papst franziskus
füllt ganze stadien hat millionen fans
jetzt muss er nur noch die charts
erobern dann ist er vollends zum popstar
geworden